you've been in many things but people
will probably know you mostly from your
work on outlander which is another show
that people have you know sort of an
intense fan um love for and so was when
this came up was there any hesitation
from on your part to enter in another
world that's so like heavily looked at
by the by
fans or were you jumping with the chance
no i did i did jump at the chance i mean
it's um it's a wonderful world to be a
part of i i'm i i was a fan of the
original series as well so when ryan uh
you know ryan and i go back
to two previous shows that we'd worked
on together and that we would meet for
lunch and we would talk about this show
house of the dragon and not that it was
called that then but this idea of a show
about the targaryens and everything and
i was like mate come on we've gotta
we've gotta do this your family has
dragons
there are power men should never have
trifled with
when i finally got the call and was like
yes we want you to be involved oh i
absolutely jumped at it but the whole
fandom thing
i
i love it i really do i love the fact
that these these shows these stories are
already beloved by people and as long as
you yourself take it seriously
um i think it's a it's a great
experience for everybody as a fan when
you were talking with ryan we like
when we get to this point we've gotta uh
stick the landing on the finale better
than game of thrones proper
yeah
well yeah didn't come up that didn't
come up it's like a cheap question no
but i you know it's um ryan
is uh a huge fan
of george's work
and has that kind of investment in it
that that a true fan has but at the same
time you know he's a writer of
television and so he understands that he
has to timber that kind of
fanboy element to himself and he
wouldn't mind me saying that about him
to to actually concentrate on what is
the bigger picture so hopefully that's
what we've done when you're going from a
kilt to armor is there a moment on set
where you're like oh man i'm kind of
missing the kill to be honest
well you miss you you you missed the
lightness of the kilt yes
yes the armor is somewhat heavier for
sure and i think dougal mckenzie at
least managed to sit down a couple of
times in outlander whereas howard
westerly never ever ever sits down
i i remember asking ryan at one point um
is there a scene where you see me
sitting i think no it doesn't snitch
so ten months of standing
that's a lot of standing um so how would
you describe your character's
relationship to
the targaryen family
well he's immensely loyal
he's immensely loyal
as uh the lord commander of the
kingsguard he has forsaken
um
the kind of things that most people take
for granted um relationships um money
titles land all of that kind of stuff
not for him he's devoting his entire
life to this family um it's almost like
a religious order really and and he is
like he is a sort of monk-like figure in
some ways
uh a little bit like the sort of uh
templar knights in that sense that you
know they're warrior knights
um who have that kind of religious
fervor and his religion just happens to
be the targaryens
um
about he is immensely devoted to them
and and he has a particularly strong
relationship with renera because she
he's known her since she was born
and has a kind of father-daughter
relationship with her to some degree and
i think personally was very pleased when
he sees that she has been
chosen to be heir to the throne
yeah so given his sort of familial
loyalty to the targaryens but he is very
like i guess personal loyalty to renee
do you feel like
when this inevitable conflict happens
i'm sure you can't tell me to answer
this will he side with her
yes
um
i can't say
um it was coming out of my mouth and i
was like easily answer this i can't
answer that question uh no he's um
the only thing i can say about harold
for sure
is that he is always guided by what he
believes is right
right
you know morally right and that that
shapes his path
in everything
and uh unlike
many of the people who inhabit the world
of houses
if you had a personal dragon have you
given any thought as to what you would
name it
oh
that's a great question
that's i've tried not to think too much
about it because it was so denied me
when i got the job i turned to my kids
and i said i'm in this show and dragons
in this do you have a dragon dad i don't
know
it doesn't have a dragon no so i was a
bit disappointed about that so it's a
bit of a sore point but um
what would i name it what would i name
it
um
i think i think harold would have quite
a sort of sweet name
not you know not like draxis or whatever
they're called or you know
all these kind of really harsh sounding
words maybe something like um i don't
know
because he's very confident in his own
masculinity he doesn't need to have this
kind of big kind of look at my dragon
name it's just like hey this is luke
[Music]